[Music]
thank you
Richard welcome to spec page TV now
you're the telegraph's agony Uncle um
tell us how you fell into that role
well it's the first time that I've been
a newspaper Agony Aunt Agni Uncle
however you want to phrase it
um but actually I think one of the
reasons that I was quite Keen to do it
when Graham Norton left has Graham did
it for quite a few years and then he
left and they offered it to me was
because I realized that I'd sort of done
quite a lot of that kind of thing on on
this morning when Judy and I presented
this morning you know we used to do a
phone in every day I think they still do
a phone in every day um but we had an
Agony Aunt Denise Robertson who was a
wonderful woman from from Sunderland
from the Northeast uh and you know we
did this morning for 13 14 years and
that's an Agony phoning on a huge range
of subjects you know it could be
anything could be could be sex it could
be money it could be relationships of
some kind could be work problems I mean
you know you name it the kind of the
whole kind of gamma of what an Agony
page is full of and we did it for 13
years pretty much every week and I kind
of I suppose imbibed a degree of I think
wisdom is too self-aggrandizing a word
to use but certainly experience in in
analyzing other people's problems and I
found I can't enjoyed it and I've always
enjoyed reading Agony columns and when
Graham Norton was doing it in the
telegraph
unless there was a big news story on
that Saturday morning because he did it
on Saturdays as I do
um it was always the first page I turned
to used to be on the back of the
strategy section and unless as I say
there was something I knew I had to read
first that would be the first thing I
did I'd go to the to the Saturday
section and read his column because it
was funny and it was wise and it was it
could be very very dry in a witty sense
um and I just loved it and when I read
that that he'd gone it in fact it was
the week he left he wrote a little sort
of paragraph saying well guys I've had a
great time doing this for five six years
whatever but this is my last column I
was really really fed up you know I knew
I was going to miss it and then
literally five minutes later the phone
went and it was the telegraph saying
would I like to do it and I said you
absolutely you know in a heartbeat and I
took over do you have a process like do
you have something that you you like
doing breaking down a problem or uh is
there is there do you ever ask for
advice on the advice that you're giving
uh I tend not to do the latter
um what I tend to do is look for the
real message in the letter
because in my experience it's not always
the case but in my experience a lot of
the time uh the real problem is buried
not completely it kind of pokes through
the paragraphs here and there but what
people are really asking me or what's
really giving them the issue that they
want me to help them deal with
um they're almost in denial about I mean
I had a typical letter this week a guy
who's married to a younger wife uh
they've got a couple of young children
together he's in his mid 50s she's in
her mid-30s and unless it was ostensibly
about a skiing trip which he'd organize
for them later this year and he was
saying to me that he'd want to appear
enthusiastic for his wife because she
was desperate to go on the skiing trip
but secretly he was dreading it and he
went on to list reasons which didn't
really seem to add up he said I mean I
went skiing 25 30 years ago with some
young mates from Union that it was a
disaster and I kept falling over and I'm
dreading that happening again but that's
his one and only skiing holiday and he
said um and I'm you know my wife wants
us to have lessons in the morning and
the kids to have kids lessons and that's
all just to ski in the afternoon and I
don't think that will work I was
thinking well why why wouldn't that work
and then eventually out it came what it
was really about it was this fear of
getting older he said in the final
paragraph almost as a throwaway he said
of course I'm not as young as I was and
then this was the real giveaway he said
um and I'm worried that this will be the
thin end of the wedge and this will be
the first older dad's activity that I
can't do
so that was that was his problem so my
answer to him was very direct I said
you're not really worried about going
skiing at all are you because one
everybody falls over on their first
skiing trip so what happened 25 years
ago is irrelevant
um and and two what you're really
worried about is getting older and
that's all in your head you don't make
any mention of not being fit or well or
anything like that so this is just you
being frightened um of making a bit of a
fool of yourself and you know being
caught out for being older and you won't
be loads of people start skiing in their
mid 50s in their 60s and they learned to
ski competently and confidently so this
is a problem that's purely in your head
ignore it and go skiing
um so that's an example of how you I
anyway try and look for the real causal
factor and while people have written to
me that's so interesting and the thing
when you first took on this role you
said that you wanted to be helping
people not to be judgmental but do you
think that sometimes you have to be a
little bit judgmental especially if the
person is not necessarily the best
behaved uh person in the scenario that
they're describing maybe they're the
source of their own unhappiness do you
think that you have yes what's that
balance like
I think it you you must never be cruel
and you must acknowledge that they've
written to you because they're in need
you know not necessarily in despair but
they're in need but very often they're
Their Own Worst Enemy uh and you it's a
bit like being very honest with a friend
there's no point if a friend comes to
you and lays out a problem in
pussyfooting around if you think
actually they're the problem and their
attitude is actually what has to change
rather than the world around them
um so I will be quite blunt quite often
in in my column and I think that
actually is is an old tradition of of of
Agony Arts particularly you know 50 60
70 years ago and at the turn of the
century they were very blunt with with
some of the people who wrote into them
I'm not as blunt as they might have been
like pull yourself together young ones
and all this
um but I will be straight and I'll say
look I'm sorry if you find this a little
bit harsh when I what's the point of
asking me for advice if I don't give it
to you straight and being honest with
you I think you're I think you're the
one with the problem and this is why and
this is how I think you can fix it so
yeah quite often I I kind of I didn't
throw the letter back in their faces but
I do I kind of confront them with
actually their own prejudices their own
faults their own weaknesses yeah but
a bit of constructive criticism
absolutely
yeah if the more traditional Agni ants
that tanith Carey writes about in this
week's spectator you know she traces it
back all the way to the Victorian era
where Agony aunts really kind of
um Consolidated gender roles we might
say effectively telling women to go back
to the kitchen or not to go on a date
with a boy or anything like that I mean
quite an interesting route I think to
this type of tradition
I think that's a very interesting point
I read that I I've read the article and
and she's absolutely right that is what
they did they kind of reinforced social
stereotypes
um they as you say they reinforced the
role of a little woman in the kitchen
you know uh I think there was one letter
to a um a young woman who was concerned
that she was to use the word of the time
um a Frump and and the reason that she
felt it front was because she ate a lot
of chocolates and all that kind of thing
these days you probably get a reply
which referred her to a therapist um and
a dietitian and all the rest of it but
back then it was a very blunt you know
put yourself together
um stop eating chocolate
um otherwise you know you'll never find
a man
um so yes they were they were I think
they could be quite unreconstructed
types those those early Agony aunts they
weren't any Agony uncles in those days
as far as I'm aware
um uh yeah re reinforcing as I say
social stereotypes at the time well just
on that Richard you know you just
mentioned that there weren't I need
uncles at that time as an Agony Uncle do
you feel a different
um approach to the role than a woman
might have do you feel that you have to
be perhaps less judgmental because
you're a man
it's a really good question I think the
area that I feel I wouldn't say
uncomfortable in but I am probably more
thoughtful and careful in my choice of
language
is when I get a question or a problem
about a sexual matter
something that's going wrong in the
bedroom
and I think
I'm prepared to be shot down in flames
for saying this but I think that that
with women Agony aunts are probably
better and more sensitive at dealing
with those issues than the male Agony
uncle is at least potentially so I don't
shy away from answering those letters
but I do acknowledge that my my
masculinity of a particular generation
because I'm in my mid-60s now
um my
what's the word might come across as
maybe a little inappropriate so I'm very
very I'm I think very very carefully
about how I phrase the reply at that
Richard go and give us an example
um well it depends where the Letter's
from
um if it's it's it's usually more often
actually from a man I don't get that
many I'm not I'm not a sex Agony uncle
and I say that usually the head of the
replies to those letters I say look I'm
not a sex therapist this is not my
specialty but you've asked me and this
is what I think I I tend to get more
letters about it from men that I do from
women they seem more comfortable talking
to me about it as a man and again we did
a lot of sex foundings on on this
morning an awful lot some of them were
incredibly Frank considering it was
daytime you know it was going out at
like 11 11 30 in the morning I get fewer
from women but I get some and it's
almost always about their husbands
um so there that's I can deal with that
um because you know I'm a husband I'm a
man and
although a lot of people don't accept
this men do talk to each other actually
about sex issues and that they're not
these days all buttoned up so you know
there is a dialogue out there to be
accessed
um but I'm all I'm saying is that and
it's probably old-fashioned on me but as
a man I just feel a little bit more
potentially compromised so I'm very I
will answer the question as frankly as I
can but I'm I tread very carefully
well Richard thank you so much for
joining Space TV
very pleasant nice talking to you
[Music]
foreign